what's good every [ __ ] nation Greg alpha
here is John over here John Bailey over
here John Bailey epic voice guy voice of
honest trailers and there's a lot more
than the trailer voice verse avoid every
celebrity you know unless one of our
reward tiers on patreon is that whatever
you want us to talk about or react to we
will definitely do it and put it up on
YouTube and today is from Andrew Hayes
the worst acted scenes in movie history
from the channel looper I have never
seen a bad actor seen in my life I think
I'm the best actor ever you can tell by
my delivery right now cheer me up javi
the quality of an active on screen might
be a matter of opinion most of the time
but there are some performance is so
awful but all subjectivity goes out the
window in the case of DC the acting is
so over-the-top over the summer that
it's hard not to laugh at them even
years after that's like early version
knock-knock look at that stuff just
about everyone involved in the
adaptation of 70 - vampire where else
could be accused of burning it in
Twilight's MVP Kristen Stewart takes
stuff with us Apple s performance in the
movies climactic scene it all starts
with a tree or many apps look around
looking for something to eat when they
stumble across the color clad playing
baseball while they protected human pet
watches on a stand of issues and bombers
and easily war James catches a whiff of
Bella and gets
munches
[Music]
the situation is diffused but not done
James the truck it vampire bounce the
hunted down and talking about the three
weeks away from the cousins and savagely
snaps away Bela's sparkly vampire
boyfriend
edwin arrives to save up from sowing
death but James still manages to sink
his teeth into the venom from his body
starts to spread throughout banks right
away which is when she informed everyone
in Mayas luminousness
exquisite grunting in the floor it's
coming out with traditional acting
devices like facial expressions for the
first time not too hungry I was like
what is he doing he's worse than Shane
like every five seconds I just thought
they'd see tech responsibility
yeah it was one or two only one or two
guys we're good
[Laughter]
the original ending Freeman turns Spacey
and shoot what are you doing so graphic
and he's already been there's nothing to
do with any of this mess but we never
get to see the contents
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Wow who's practically president of the
Keanu Reeves fan club had to admit to
Entertainment Weekly
it was helping to affect an English
accent he tried that was the problem
actually he wanted to do it perfectly
and keep trying to do it perfectly
he came off as stupid yeah or of course
the ottoman presents to major movie
that's all right came back together so
geoduck swishes bendable footsteps
October's not one of those things is not
like yellow Jake Gyllenhaal's
breakthrough performance as home Aikman
in October Sky features him standing up
to the status quo I'm dying to the
mineshaft up to school with his dad
instead he literally reaches to the sky
doesn't want to be space cadet who built
Rockets on the slide it builds to a
poignant moment a father-son friction
that totally resonates the way it should
now won't you inner struggling you were
struck in your rocket son
thirty hours later man that's to james
Van Der Beek's right down with his own
pulp in boss tiegler's which hit
theaters a few weeks before they the
movie been a big place a backup about
Janet boy was I dancing yeah whose hi
he's way to the studies what I saw this
movie when I was like six leaders of my
family family play what Marx has no such
ambitions and tells it as much in the
most exaggerated and let's see I can't
tell now if they're just talking about
worst acting with their worst accident
cream Bob wood I think to be fair though
it was spider mystery the whole movie
spider-man do something good it's not
that great to either but I mean
everybody's portraits Stanley was the
only good part of that would that came
here
we spit threats out getting payback the
whole thing adds up to a scene walk-up
tradition under the comics it was
baseline rain rain go away try Andy with
down never quite lived up to the promise
she displayed in rubies from the late
80s and early 90s maybe it was because
of the performance in for weddings in
appear what [ __ ] required although
the film is otherwise moderately Tommy
there's one scene that tends to ruin it
on every rate watch and they heard the
baby in the pouring rain gee grant the
way this one of those classic sappy
it was you all along speeches to Miguel
but his monologue is interrupted by one
observation I'll tell you my favorite
worst moments was in the mummy when
she's like take that Pembridge scholars
it was like nails on a chalkboard very
every time you know who I can't say
there's an actor who I just can't stand
who I think all his performances should
be on this list season is I can't stand
the actor however guys last is a Peter
Sarsgaard
Peter stars oh yeah like sleepy
to be fair though I thought he did I
thought he did okay despite the how bad
the movie was I thought he did okay and
Green Lantern
really yeah considering how bad the
movie was he played a good crazy person
yeah that's one of the few times where
opinions are objective I get surprised
when studios or TV shows don't recast
when someone is evidently terrible yeah
cuz in Twilight Kristen Stewart is
easily the worst one out of everyone
who's already bad but it's really
uncomfortable she looks she really looks
like she doesn't want to be there it
kind of reminds her like Finn Jones an
iron fist like why do you keep him
around even though no one seems to like
the guy at all and I kind of feel that
you could have done that with Kristen
Stewart here locks in at that point
there probably yes I mean I can
understand it they caught it early on
enough and she wasn't somebody where
they get me like Marty McFly so she
never may you never know it could be
like in the freakin contract where
they're just kind of stuck with them or
it may just be one of those things where
they because they don't film it in order
or they don't you know maybe because
until it's finished an edited you don't
really realize how bad it is who's the
director of that there you go not one of
the great female directors of the modern
era right now I never noticed I watched
I was like what is really is your nose
not gonna stay on ER I never miss
teenager kick is okay if you were all
nervous teenage boys at one point have
you ever done this like seven times in a
row well I think it depends to scene
with painful awkwardness yeah it does
make it painfully okay that is
maybe his acting she's automatically on
their take you mean tick yeah one part
of your face to keep yeah and then he
based his whole character around this
tick I'm the nose guy you know he would
do this to Cassie I was always like just
wiping my hands off of my face my hand
my palms get sweaty that would at least
that one wouldn't have been quite so
in-your-face is there let's cover my
entire faces my hands okay seriously I
can't do this reaction anymore I think
it's fascinating that Richard Linklater
like took responsibility for that though
yeah usually you don't see the dream
should be like yep I screwed up my fault
it's not and he seems like the kind of
guy I would do that too he seems like
the kind of director would be just up
front because he wasn't like we couldn't
work around it he thought it was a good
thing or just ignoring the question
altogether like I don't know doesn't
look like anything to me Julie Julie man
I've got chili really well yeah like why
do I have to its cry of excuse my wife
made me hide to see how terrible was and
what's really surprising about it's
really boring yeah that's the sad part
about it if it was like entertaining bad
I could have settled for that I enjoy
badly bad movies yeah badly they're
badly okay I like that bad movies that
are bad in a funny way or they're
tolerable at least but mad moves that
are boring and it's not good cuz this
movie takes itself seriously like Al
Pacino gives one of his longest
monologues ever and that one scene he
has and he's really committed to its
cause and how much better flick has
changed his career with this even seven
though man I I'm so surprised it's on
this list I feel like that's one of
those debate ones because I feel like
I've heard this before into some people
agree and some I guess unless your
wife's heads in a box I don't know how
you would react so wax house in a box
right yeah
that way if his wife said isn't I had
been that situation I know what I would
have done yeah I think I would have
acted better
I mean like so your mom's in a box
losing is she exactly maybe acting badly
wasn't yeah you know I mean jeez because
I've never seen Brad Pitt behave like
that yeah and in that moment I'm like
yeah you're kind of hysterical exactly
yeah I mean you lost all the reality of
what just happened to setting yeah and
you're like this can't really be happy
but you're still trying to be a cop at
the st. like DC's all cuts like we can
feel what he's doing yeah there's like a
Schrodinger severed head probably my
wife it's not what I
doesn't want to believe it he's angry
he's sad he's got a lot going on worse
than what our imaginations even thought
it could have been yeah it could have
been like parts of her or it could have
been just her internal organs jeez it
could have been so what are people
looking for their souls yeah that's like
pulp fiction that would have been their
greatest was a golden heart yeah I'm
surprised they just narrowed it down to
one Frances for a couple of quote was
quite interesting actually because I
thought that what I was actually
watching it maybe he was so concerned
with trying to do the voice that he
become scyatta reeves already in the
early 90s was a pretty stiff actor I
mean I gotta feel like that statement
though is kind of just Tim generally
because I feel like he really does want
to be a good actor I think he tries I
think he's had lots and lots of coaching
and acting classes I think he's just not
good at some things he's done I think
when he finally just embraces that he is
the surfer dude and starts making those
movies he'll be much better because
that's who he is he needs to stick to
who he is he's good at like the quieter
body language roles I've been saying for
long to have a lot of you are in love
with John
I was one of the people who didn't love
it I liked it and thought was a lot of
cool gun food to watch yeah but as far
as him as an actor I think him not
saying anything
would it make a cooler movie they would
have it if he had not have talked at all
John one or two lines maybe but not just
no no no key oh noes just just look good
and don't say crap just keep your mouth
shut John wick too when he talks more I
would get pulled out like oh this is
discounters exacting yes he does yeah
and I think it's because of exactly what
he said I think he tries way too much
too hard
oh and knock knock he's surprisingly not
bad he also had one of my one of my what
I think is one of the worst lines ever
delivered where when he has to he's in
the matrix and he's like what do you
need he's like oh just no don't say
anything at all never surprised looks
like but it's not I'm from the south and
it's not that bad but you can feel him
kind of slipping in and out again I
don't feel like this is worst acting I
think this is we're getting into worst
accents yeah he's now cuz I don't think
that was necessarily a badly acted
moment he obviously was not great with
the accident if you want to talk about
bad accents where Chris Hemsworth tried
so hard to all these other naturally and
they just come across as really really
weird and bad loving Liam Neeson is
pretty bad yeah oh it's hard Butler
though another accent to save his life I
get so much sound like work for Gerard
Butler trying to do an American accent
that's what he's trying to do and he's
trying to be American but it's not
working he's talking like the right side
of it exactly more problem boy Oakley
because I've been working on that Geo
what are the geosphere storms yes I've
been doing that he's doing another
American character like oh good yeah
here we go again lady Lola boy
he's steadily slipping into this we're
going to protect the world I did see
this movie when I was like six years old
with my family it's not a comfortable
like you had children we dad watch this
with your children sure when my son is
old enough to talk about the birds and
the bees will give it's honestly I think
it's pretty good movie it's good so many
of the movies out there have been at
least that dirge on removing like
football so it was so cut paper you know
this one has person cookie cutter yeah
yeah this one has a little bit of
something that you weren't expecting
like let's go out there for five minutes
and be God's on the field and it's
r-rated - yeah exactly so that one's
like PG or pg-13 and this was a good
like coming-of-age teen day movie like
my wife and I were dating when this
movie came you know you know what I'm
know we haven't never done that we're
both of us are like no not message I
don't know it's sexy while we're doing
things but then cleaning up afterwards
not cool I did it with maybe there's
already enough way
[Applause]
you Tildy monetize the video yeah off of
references without being clear-cut Oh
James right man Franco Franco I because
when he doesn't love a project he agreed
to be a part of he lets it be known oh
yeah cuz he can be amazing in a movie he
gonna be amazing if he really cares
about the movie yeah and if he doesn't
he's like all right I'm gonna
intentionally do a bad job over acts and
pop my cuz I never wanted to see a James
Franco move because my introduction to
him wasn't Freaks and Geeks it was
spider-man and I didn't like any of his
spider-man movies oh yeah that would
suck if that was your first actually
really good yeah you're totally right
127 hours or yeah and Spring Breakers
I'm even like he's annoying movie to me
but I still think he does a good job for
what the movie is so like I think James
Franco is a really good actor when he
cares about the movie yeah I mean it's
the right role he was great in
spider-man 1 as just playing you know
the best man in love with his girl that
he's in love with spider-man 2 was
actually a great film expect it's one of
the best superhero comic book movies
ever made still but Franco just started
seeing where his character was going and
didn't like it Oh spider-man 3 was bad
and I think because he already could
tell that he's like I was fit right in
[Music]
experience with this movie I had seen
Notting Hill I had seen Love Actually
and I was like I want to see the origin
like their big first movie before and I
wanted to see the beginning pink romance
origin romance discover where love comes
with your nose
chic and then I watch this and I
couldn't stand it because of her
performance I mean of all of the scenes
of the movie - the big romantic in the
rain is it still raining I totally
didn't notice anymore because I wet Oh
like it's just all right well looper
thanks for the list
got a question for you rejects what are
your summary your favorite worse acted
scenes that's a weird question or
favorite worst accents more least
favorite best words
yeah what's what is worse what is still
not good I like in this world put in the
common pot that's what they're for you
will subscribe to the real rejects with
a hate comment click that notification
bell - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram patreon become a patreon
rejected a Andrew hey thanks for
requesting this video and there's no
need to promote you John John Bailey
epic voice guy his YouTube channels solo
channel he does RIF reactions as well I
got a lot of his own content view movies
and all this trailers boys guy y'all
know that already this guy is really
friendly and personable and he's funny
personally love this guy I've ever seen
tonight when I when I do they even to be
like great Elvis's percival the trailer
for your life comes in I want you to
just snap one day and only be a bad boy